hello and welcome back we are on cmake
episode four
and this time i'm just going to talk
about versioning your source code
didn't really talk about maybe maybe
this should be earlier but it doesn't
it doesn't matter i need to cover the
core stuff too i've basically been
covering
my favorite stuff instead all right so
if you want to verse in your source code
well just to get started here i've
opened the old project we've been
working on in the first three videos
opened in visual studio code and we've
got this root level
cmakelist.txt and
where you have your project that's where
you can add a version and what you do is
you just add
version here and then a version number
and now what we want to do is we
actually want the source code to know
what version that we are working with
so in order for the source code to need
to to know this
we're going to have to add a header file
that goes to our binary directory where
we're building to
and so to do that we'll go configure
file and
we basically need a header file
for the input and like a header file for
the output
so we'll just do like olas
config yeah we'll do config
dot h dot n and then you need an output
file
so we'll do olas config.h
so there's an n and then just a dot h
okay so now what we need to do is we
need to actually
tell our source where to be able to find
this
so we don't necessarily need our
libraries to know our version it's
mainly our
course source file so
what we want to do is we underneath this
executable here
we'll go target include directories
and we'll just put in
the name of the project which we'll keep
using the macro for now
just project underscore name
and we'll we'll call this one public
uh blick and then
here we're gonna use another special
macro
for where it builds to that way it
doesn't matter where the user is
deciding to build it to
and this this macro is part of cmake
it's project
binary dir so that's where it's getting
written to
so we want to include the binary
directory we're building to
as an include and the reason for that is
we're going to write this
dot h out to there and it will have the
version number
so it needs to know where to find that
dot h and that's what this whole point
of
this target include directories is so
now we actually need to make this
dot in file and to do that we'll just go
add another file
we'll just do it on our root level here
i'm going to do it just using
visual studio code and we're going to
call this
olas
config
dot h dot n so it's got to be that
first one we specified right there
so now we'll make this file and what we
want to have here is sort of a
macro that will get figured out
when we actually try to compile and
stuff so we'll define
and we need the project name here so
it's
going to be that version major
and then at and we'll need the same word
oh oh lass so all right oh last of
course will be
your project name it's just uh our lord
and savior here
and just double check that that's
actually what i named it up
so this needs to match this isn't
something that you can project name in
as far as i know
once you're in this header
and then we'll do version
major and we'll do
another one here again right below it
it's gonna copy line down
and we'll do a version minor
minor okay
now when cmake configures this header
it'll find
the values and they'll be these will be
replaced
and it'll find the value based on this
of course of course the first one is
major the second one's minor
so let's go back here
and let's see do we need anything else
okay we need to modify our main
we've already set we've already given
the include directories so
now we can just go include
and it'll be olas config
dot h
all right it doesn't see this right now
but it will as soon as we
update our cmake
so let's go ahead and preemptively do a
little printing out of the version
there's a couple ways we can do this i'm
going to go ahead and put
the r c
um hint our count
care pointer to an array
part v
and of course the first argument is
always your program name
so we're just going to use that in this
little output here is kind of the point
there
you don't really have to launch it with
any anything we just want to say
uh rb0
which will of course be the name of the
program
and then we'll say version just
just to confirm it all works here and
then we need
that define so we need this version
major and version minor
that's going to be the variable name
that's figured out that compile time
so we'll say the version major and we'll
put a
dot and then we'll say
minor
and then we can just end the line here
i'm just gonna
do a new line with no flush and there we
go
so that there should spit it all out so
let's go ahead and
run cmake again
and i'm just going to i'll manually type
in the commands here
let's make this a little bigger so
people can actually see it
so i'm going to change directory oops
change directory to our project
first
and then let's take a look at the files
real quick
it's kind of kind of large everything's
there we've got our config
and now when we update cmake we'll go
cmake
source uh source cmakes in this
directory
and the build one is in out slash build
this is what we're building to
and i could use those sh files i made
last
time but i'm going to avoid that this
time
so it looks like it wrote everything and
now
when we build which is
just make run the make file that's in
our eight
in our out slash build does its thing
looks like it didn't have any errors
and now we should be able to run
oh
it
there it is no less there we go
so now when we run this it shows the
name of the
of what we ran since we ran it from back
a couple directories that's why we've
got
we've got all this on it but it does now
show the version as you can see
and of course it also pops up the window
from that library we did with sub
modules
last time
and that's really pretty much it for
versioning
now what happens is anytime you update
this version here
it is automatically updated on in your
source code
so your source code has access to the
version of your program that way you can
run
checks like maybe you want to check for
backwards compatibility
or something like that way in the future
when you're changing things
now you can just grab the version
because you might know
oh i've changed something uh if you're
using a version this old it won't work
so that way you can check
when the user goes to run it
and things like that and also you know
any other thing you might need to know
the version for
but that's pretty industry standard
there for
your projects you
you want to have a version at least a
major and minor if nothing else
thanks for watching this episode of
cmake how to i'll see you guys in the
next episode
peace out